this is the story that just keeps on
giving controversy continues to build
over country star jason aldean and his
wife's transphobic comments yeah in case
you haven't been following along jason's
influence for wife brittany aldean faced
some serious backlash for our posting a
makeup reveal video writing along it
i'd really like to thank my parents for
not changing my gender when i went
through my tomboy phase i love this
girly life
and catching that transphobic caption
was country artists like uh cassidy pope
brandi carlisle and maren morris who all
stood up for the queer community cassidy
took to twitter writing you'd think
celebs with beauty brands would see the
positives including the lgbtq plus
people in their messaging but instead
here we are hearing someone compare
their tomboy phase to someone wanting to
transition real nice yeah with the
outspoken mirror morris chiming in
replies to cassidy's tweet it's so easy
to like not be a scumbag human sell your
clippings and zip it insurrection barbie
and the surprise twist we didn't see
coming trying to capitalize on marin's
barbie comment brittany then launched a
barbie inspired don't tread on your our
kid's clothing line
however amidst the growing backlash it
was revealed that jason aldean had been
dropped from his longtime publicity firm
while britney continues to stand by her
controversial statements in a new
appearance on fox news tucker carlson
tonight here's what she had to say
were you surprised by this
yes i was extremely surprised i you know
in saying my response i never thought
that there was anything wrong with it
i think i'm advocating for children i
think that children should not be
allowed to make these life-changing
decisions at such a young age they are
not mature enough
they
are just they should have parents that
love them and advocate for them
regardless
we have ages on everything right we have
it for cigarettes we have it for driving
we have it for military voting
yet for some reason people or think that
we can
let a child choose their gender so young
it's very baffling to me well especially
when
that process is irreparable i mean you
wind up castrating children removing
their sex organs making them sterile for
life i mean these are huge consequences
huge consequences and i think when
you're older if you choose to make those
decisions by all means but children are
too young not mature enough to make
those decisions and they're
life-changing like you said they may not
be able to have
children one day there's so many
consequences to doing that at such a
young age and us as parents us as a
society regardless of political status
should be able to sit back speak our
minds about it and fight for these
children
please make us feel better and tell us
that you know people in nashville who've
called you personally to say they're on
your side
so much support so much support
especially people that have children
um there's definitely you have the other
the side of that too and that's fine
people are entitled to their opinions
but that's just it we as conservatives
have a very hard time having an opinion
especially in society today in the media
in relationships in the workplace and
it's very very sad but a lot of support
within nashville and just friends and
family for sure
joining us now to weigh in is our
resident country queen katie colley
hello ladies thank you for having me hey
girl um okay first of all there is so
much here brittany aldean and tucker
carlson what a duo that was a lot to
watch um first of all it's wild to me
that britney is still defending her
comments after even saying on her
instagram at one point that her comments
were taken out of context um
and you know it's shocking that she was
surprised by the backlash but also it
just shows you how much the country
music community is still so far behind
and not caught up with these times um
as a huge country music fan myself it's
days like this and stories like this
that i'm very ashamed that i'm a fan
um and you know it's just really sad to
see the amount of people that are
agreeing with brittany and supporting
her as she says in nashville she's
gotten a lot of support
um as for her comments about
gender after gender affirming surgery
i don't think she has any place to speak
about that when she hasn't gone through
that herself
it doesn't sound like she is close to
anyone who has gone through that herself
and that's not something that just
happens overnight you know this is a
long pro process that a child a teen an
adult goes through to get to that point
you don't just come to that decision and
do that the next day you know you're
talking to your parents you're
going to therapy about it you're talking
to doctors it's not it doesn't just
happen
and i think that's what's being missed
out of all of her comments there
i think katie you make a really good
point this goes back to her original
comment that she made on that makeup
video that
let's start with that first in her
talking about you know my parents not
changing me or tom i listen i was a
tomboy i mean that's not even the point
this is this remark was completely wrong
what she said it was tone deaf and now
she's building on top of this post that
she did and now she's changing her voice
and doing a whole different discussion
so this is what bothers me the most
about this whole thing yeah i think the
tomboy phase to compare that is
literally like that just tells me you
don't know anything and why are you even
speaking on something you don't even
know so that's one aspect of this that
frustrates me but then the other
comments that she made like yeah my son
wants to be a dinosaur and one day my
daughter wants to be a cat how dare you
compare that that actually infuriates me
to double down on something like that
and to be so ignorant you know you're
allowed to have your opinion about
things that is okay it is a free country
that we imagine but when you're ignorant
about them and you're so passionately
ignorant i struggle with that i
understand you know having
issues trusting the medical community
you know they're especially in america
it's very different there you know
they'll tell you your kid has adhd to
put them on drugs just so they can make
money i understand there's some mistrust
with the medical community i also am of
the mind that i really believe that when
children are adults they should make
adult decisions
how big or how small but adult decisions
when they are of age and i feel that
about everything tattoos drinking
minuscule things to big decisions like
that and also i don't have kids but i
would imagine being protective of my kid
in one way where i don't want you to go
and do surgery i don't want anyone
touching you i don't want anything
happening to you there's that protective
side but also what people fail to
realize is kids in the lgbt community
people in general in that community they
struggle a lot struggle and so many
people speak for them all the time
misspeak for them and try to represent
them and you don't know what a child's
mental health is like i know when i was
eight years old i felt like a girl
you know i thought i was a girl i liked
boys that's what i knew at eight
i knew that
who am i to say another eight-year-old
who was born a girl can't know that
they're a boy and that they like this
and that they feel this way who are we
to say what you are and what you feel
and when we're not them like no one's
gonna speak for me as a black woman i
will be damned so how dare you and
that's what bothers me about this
all of it fires me up yeah and i ate as
a parent and everything oh sorry
i was just gonna say like you made a
really good point about this like
parents
are there to help you they're not gonna
rush you they're not gonna make your
decision they're there to help you make
this journey right for you yeah these
decisions are not made in an easy way
this is a big situation and she made us
so general when she was talking about it
on fox oh look at the stats of how many
kids actually do that it it's it's a
very minuscule number to just give her
facts on it let let parents parents are
not making these decisions so quickly
and that's what's bothering about this
comment i think the fact that even jason
aldean's team his pr company said
bye-bye there's a reason for that
because they realize this is a big no-no
this is not how you deal with this so
yeah uh yeah katie go ahead yeah you
were gonna say something
well in terms of the pr company i think
that has just been a long time coming
unfortunately for aldine they are very
outspoken on their views which is okay
they're allowed to be
um but i think this was ultimately like
you can't say that it's it's also
it's not doing anybody any good when you
are continuing to repeat and stand by
these points when are just so so
controversial and it's just like how do
you not realize that
um and you know jason and brittany have
children of their own it's scary to
think if they're growing up and if and
they're queer and what are their parents
going to say about that will they be
supportive of that and it just goes back
to country music as a whole and it kind
of reminded me too about morgan wallins
racial slur controversy a couple years
ago and kelsey ballerini went on twitter
and she's like well this isn't
representative of country music in
nashville but unfortunately it is
and unfortunately there's still so much
that needs to be done to further support
these communities but you know we have
come a long way there are artists like
mary morris as we've seen who
has been outspoken miranda lambert
she is a big supporter of the lgbtq plus
community so things are happening and we
are moving in a slightly
good direction but there's still so much
that needs to be done and it's just
scary to see
someone like brittany and jason like
just so mind-blown it's just
mind-blowing like educate yourself i
think first educate yourself before
you're speaking
on something like this like for britney
i'm thinking
do you know any trans person have you
spoken to them about their experience
yeah they can be traumatizing
they've gone through something that you
can't even imagine so yeah i've heard
stories of
people going through like literally
wanting to kill themselves over this
because we live in a world where you
don't feel like you can be your
authentic self so you know they're
people who literally kill themselves
over these comments that you make so i
get it i'm of the mind to protect the
children make decisions when you're an
adult of course but as a mother you
support your kids with whatever they're
going through and you try to create that
environment for them but to just make
these blanket statements about things
that you're ignorant about i just like
to me is so
actually more harmful if you want to
protect the kids you don't make
statements like that you know it's just
they're negative and yeah i think jason
should be punished because he co-signed
the comment yeah he signed no she's on a
trail yeah a media trailer yeah i can't
even remember exactly it's a good thing
or else we wouldn't beat it together
together
yeah and it was this is all because of a
makeup tutorial at the end of the day
like what do we even make sure
i know the comments are crazy we need to
go there we didn't need to do that yeah
but we did and
but yeah it's just i think you really
need to educate yourself before you're
speaking on that matter so publicly with
the platform that you have yeah do you
want to read some comments i mean all
the comments are pretty much with it
like she sounds dumb the ignorance yeah
um
they all pretty much agree i was trying
to find a comment that didn't agree to
give a balance to this story but i don't
see anybody that's the thing
and unfortunately a lot of people have
been coming after marin morris for
you know brittany and it's just when you
see the sides to it it's like how how is
maren morris now being called karen like
yeah it's knowledge comes down to
knowledge all right katie thank you so
much for joining us it was so good thank
you ladies
have a good long weekend
thank you